yes he helps what we do we do last time
and we sort of them looked at gadgets so
reducing some constraints the different
constraints and in fact it turns out
that an optimum gadget could be found by
a linear program the number of axillary
variables was if they had negation to
this thing we were reducing to like to
certain toulon the number of peculiar
variables was to the number of
satisfying assignments of this p minus
the number of primary is minus 1 and the
constraints were exponentially in this
so this was easy for to reduce from
trillion this number actually turned out
to be a 3 so everything was very nice
and cozy and then you could get optimal
gadgets or as a reduction from three in
two thumbs up you could get optimal get
it gave you DC inapproximability results
and these are the best known under NP
completeness that's a challenge to do
better there are better things are no
longer unique games but that said it's
sort of a different what is it different
game and then I discussed a little bit
could you possibly make a direct PCP
maybe the fact that you have uselessness
here you know you don't know just that
you can satisfy everything but
everything is very uniform and nice and
that didn't seem to work it gives him
forget it and the last thing I was
trying to outline is that well maybe we
should start with a different starting
point and I call it Tejada mark
predicates proving hard by chung and
then the point theory is that 87 is a
very good predicate but this is a tech
cepting configurations
and eight then this is 120 and then the
number of constraints is large and you
have to do something clever if you're
gonna solve any questions or comments or
thoughts
also how hard is it to another disguise
see abstract the linear poem by hand
I've never tried so I've tried for this
the
well even believe in verifying a
solution by hand is difficult right when
you get to these kind of things right
because then you're your ears breaking
down the gadget which has 128 axillary
variables and you're sort of hoping that
the max factor for you know the best
tool in doing this we have certain
problems I'm sorry that's obstruction
that's not to structure but I couldn't
do it by hand on your computer yes I'll
see you guys after changing not one to
too many but to close in to me
that's a good question i don't i can't i
can't say anything better than to think
of this so you have if you have two
things like this you want to think of
this as a cost twenty six variables
right you can do the same thing now we
actually have six variables and we sort
of but then we have unfortunately 16
satisfying assignments and it's starting
to kill ok but nothing prevents that I
mean possibly you can do better by
taking two I suppose I don't say after
all this all this thing would have no
such encima we can yeah just like to be
some worst case in the got it I adore
you know just to try to go along the
bosque that's an interesting question do
so you work on it I don't know the
answer um okay honey anything else from
these to do the numbers that the
segments have anything to do it like the
room code the segments because the
number is the same is there any kind of
correspondence
and the number of sample will well it's
the same number i suppose right to to
something right the number of binary
strings are a certain length it's
nothing nothing but okay so then we let
what I'm going to do today first is I I
want to prevent the hardness of this the
thing I was stating here saying that we
want the better starting point here over
it with a very sports predicate and I
started writing doubt 87 before you came
but I got tired after writing down the
first five there should be three more
strings here all right so these are the
linear functions and each string is
given by input so these you should take
the product of the corresponding bits so
you have seven non trivial linear
functions of three input and well you
get put another way to say it is that
this column for instance is the X or the
two previous columns this is a new fresh
column this guy is the actual of this
thing and that thing that column is the
X or this thing and that thing and this
column is x 4 over 3 increasing
Oh
Oh
but for the record let me say that
so if you assume the unity of conjecture
we already know that this predicate work
was a useless that you know that it's
hard to do and I'm in Snowdonia
approximation sisters but you only get
the uniform distribution in the negative
object and this was proved by some
lunatic in traditional under the unique
Jim conjecture
and must I had done this of course you
think about proving it under and be
honest but this seemed completely
hopeless I'll convince you why this is
hopeless okay
so we really sort of known to
what I'm going to prove is hopeless i
first have to prove explain to you why
it's hopeless to prove in the not prove
it all right what what are you what what
is your statement okay not now baby I'm
done a couple of these probes right we
don't know how we know how the machine
works right if you have a predicate in
mind we have this predicate in mind and
now we're just going to pick some some
some things here and some things here
maybe we'd have a couple of tables here
knows and we'll pick some questions and
then we'll make sure that you know
somehow we gonna
if you know what these things should
look like right we're going to ask if
your questions we can ask something the
small time we're going to ask them in
this big table and then we sort of want
to make sure that you know if we look at
any I you know the corresponding bits
any coordinate this should be accepted
by our pedicels that's the way we set up
these things right we've been doing it
for a couple of times and then in the
end is going to ask you know the the
corresponding bits in the tables and
they should satisfy that they should
satisfy them and if in the negative case
we'll assume we in fact want to say that
any non-trivial product of this as a low
expectation that's the way we set up
these things right
so yeah I don't get what you are proving
now that that you cannot prove get for
this particular problem from the labor
cover well yes i'm going to being so
forward but I'm we had I'm not proving
anything okay so I'm just sort of wood
to build up to chance yourself by saying
he really needed a great new idea that
goes beyond the technology we had so far
and the technology we saw had so far was
hopeless to prove what he proved that's
what I'm trying to put so that's why I
first want to discuss how would we have
gone about to prove his result if he
only had the technology I shown you so
far you mean hopeless the group of those
letter bounds for still said no no now I
left to Saturn Toulon I just want to
discuss a h7 we want to prove
uselessness 487 that you can create the
instances retort to distinguish when you
can almost always satisfy 87 and from
those where you actually get the uniform
distribution on date on the seven bit
strings when for any proof that's am I
making sense not it's not even loaded
you should not not be I'm not making so
you started to pull that h 7 is that
oxidation resistance and I'd like to
show us that the proof face and then
you're going to fix it using the chance
new ID that's great that make sense I'm
just translating what's that
good so how would we do it right we've
seen how to do these proofs over and
over again right and that is that you
know we pick some strings to the left
arm to the right then we make sure that
you know if you look at them locally you
know if you take we have three inputs
there and then we sort of have the on
the left side we need the projections
and they should all satisfy HK right and
then in the end we're going to take
these big strings and feed them into our
functions and our test would be to see
if that's satisfied educate so how would
we do in this case so the first thing is
it though so did the homework and
dominique is not here the first thing
you have to decide on which science to
which questions go on right and then you
sort of starts fiddling ok so
so any suggestions you know we now need
seven positions you know how should we
distribute them between the two sides
but we should have some on both sides
that's clear right because otherwise
we're not really testing anything so we
have our favorite picture well suppose
we even have two on the small side okay
so we start here with some
some x1 which is here
I mean suppose when you take this would
be the first to that in fact we know
that the fourth component is the XOR of
the first to write and this sort of
cells that we need the fourth bit also
to live here because it's going to be
essentially the X or maybe we can add
some noise but it's that essentially
live there okay so if we have X 1 and X
2 that sort of means that we sort of
have also here f you up
and now we are we going to produce this
mess right we want to put that any
product of these pics we're going to
read it's going to be small and in
particular we should prove that the
product of this three bits this more but
if this is just a long code that's not
consistent with anything here this bit
will be perfectly one and we'll have
some song jism so we can't prove that
all characters a linear function yeah
well if F is a correct long quote so
always the thing that once then use
thing to think about is the design
inconsistent long coach that's always a
bad there's nope that they're all
correctly specified by covering
something but they're calling nothing
something has nothing to do with the
leprechaun I don't understand one thing
about this users and then so you can
prove some care right because you can
prove if something as a gap then you can
prove that there is some gap in this
empty heart isn't fun to like or or what
I am not sure what you mean really well
that starting from legal yes are so if
you have a problem an approximation
problem which cannot be approximately
bit like let's say get I don't know like
0.1 then you can at least prove that it
cannot be approximated with 0.0001 or
well some smaller gap but you can still
prove some NP hardness yeah as you're
saying for every problem so so there
would be some a bit very at least you
achieve summit some advance right yes
but so you're saying that you make
actually boomkat you know the perfect
approximation resistant that's hard to
distinguish a wall more satisfied but
but i would get some other factor yeah
yeah yeah and this is definitely true
because for instance the champion
implies parity of the first second and
fourth bit yeah but if you are proving
uselessness doesn't it mean that you
cannot prove any get up front so ever or
useless useless this is the perfect a
trap the saying that even if you can
satisfy everything no character I mean
in a good case these strings will almost
always satisfy the product that I have
in mind which is extremely sparse on top
of it and if the bad cases would be
uniformly distributed stroke so useless
Nazis I mean does not imply yeah yeah
okay now I get it but but but if I was
contending us getting some a pro in the
probability which are not getting this
so the perfect number now is like 2 to
the K over 2 to the 2 to the K minus 1
right this is the fraction accepted and
this is the number of total string this
is what I'm going for right that's the
approximate bility factor I want if I
was happy with something smaller I could
get something because that point is I
can control some terms in this Fourier
expansion and in particular I can embed
the pirating here because just if I take
a parity instance and put that in in
places 12 and forth in the predicate
that Willie's given in the probability
factor a half of a also a chunk read it
yet yeah
and good but the problem is that it's if
you put even two strings on the Exide
there to satisfy this property will have
a third string on the Exide okay and
this probably means I have something
that looks and now I am I going to do
uselessness I want to do old products in
particular I want to do the product of
the three bits that all live on get on
there on the F side but if F on itself
is just it and then long code that has
nothing to do with the g-type this term
will be big because it is just a parity
of three bits and the target of these
strings is one right so I can't control
it and so this means the sort of should
have only one string here if I'm gonna
have any hope for controlling six and
six guys over here but then you start
saying what now you just say well take a
product of 3g things here or which I
know the XOR and if this is a correct
long code which is inconsistent but i
have here i mean i have some i have some
extra or on these six bit that's also
gonna be piasa i'm going to be screwed
unless they choose an independently well
how I'm going to choose things I'm
eyelid I'll clearly want to choose I'll
choose an X on this side and then i'll
choose why i won I need to make sure
that things are like a x pi i if i put
this in the first place and then i have
y tu I y6 they should be existed by by
the predicate right because it will
never not accepted by the predicate ok
and this means that it clear that d but
you can read off right I'm taking all
these fits on the white side and the XOR
of these two guys for instance is that
guy yeah so they don't have so if I now
ask f of X 0 y 1
alright
yes
Oh
so if you take some terms a term like
this right now I'm going to take all the
possible sub products here I want them
all to be small right that's how I prove
yourselves so some guys will be easy to
control instance this one these are in
fact two independent pit stop so
something like this will be easy control
this will automatically be 0
and if you look at one like this
this is the first component the second
component when I do this wrong yeah oh
sorry this one is actually to control
because these are independent these guys
are these first three positions and the
third is X or the first two games but
also this can become control because
this is exactly what we did in the
parity analysis this will have the same
distribution as we are having the parity
so this will be easy to control
um
now along the other hand
this will be extremely problematic to
control because these are three strings
on the Y side which in fact are perfect
external can't control
the structure label cover the bipartite
as if we had insulating cover we had a
team-high compartment drop which had
hardened we started from that you won't
have this wire or you have not so he
just managed to be two on each because
we are going to put three on one
particular on the same side that's the
reason the problem yes but somehow yeah
we could sort of think of having two
guys over here and then you can sort of
think what you want right but if you're
always wanting to travel somehow so what
you can do what Samsung's summary needs
to be deceitful we have unique games and
then in fact you can have one question
in each place and we're doing extremely
well but not as long as we have a sort
of massive projections here we will
indeed trouble because we're going to
get correlations and no substance
and
where Apple
now the thing we're going to do
he was going to take products and proof
systems
and so we'll have a proof system that we
call the product of q1 and q2 will have
questions which are you know you pick a
random question in each other to proof
systems
actually so in the first room system we
should have gotten t bit so this is 1
and in the second proof system you
should have also put in to bit I will
just take the product of these things in
that I mean the way they won this
program works for on the system you just
take the product
Lola's proven assented to questions
looks at you know see what what the
[ __ ] in it position should be and it's
just a product of the corresponding so
another question well so let's suppose
we did what I just said right we have
one proof system the professional
Tippett do you have is that will take
one question here will take six
questions over here 112 by six and these
are the questions right so then we'll
have to take another copy of the same
proof system where we will actually have
start take pick a random new table here
we're going to pick so this is sort of
index one and we'll ask one question
here i will pick a possible guy over
here and we'll have
it should be to write six questions over
here and then let a question would in
the combined proof system a question we
look like and in fact we're going to put
this guy in a different position well
well it could look we're going to change
this one right that a question the
combined fuel system is I have one
position here one position there please
give me the and write down the XOR of
these two bits as the proof in in the
new roof system I mean the same you know
you have six more questions here yeah
yeah but what the chocolate
okay so if this is set of accepted
strings is a subgroup this works
perfectly okay so in the in the binary
this one what by the way what I'm saying
is going to work or brandy and I'm you
know mod Q remotely we ran in any group
but I'm going to do it in the deck short
okay
right because if you had original proof
system where this was to expect it to be
in a strange set and that was expected
to be in a different strange that when
we had the pairwise product it would be
you know maybe everything example but if
these belong to the same linear subspace
the throat I mean the point-wise product
which is just the sum belongs to the
same subspace if we don't have to change
the acceptance criteria all right
so let's fairy princess thank you
without this a one what you want to
well this shouldn't be right this is
what i wrote this problem before I would
even say I wrote this incorrectly before
right oh we sorta have really reading
teeth different positions like I wrote
they say all this is kyu won before they
should be okay the proof is the same
only the question Freddie's like that we
get to independent it doesn't have to be
the say it could be any to proof system
with the to any type to prove i'm going
to use it with essentially the same
written proofs but doesn't matter but
the verifier reads from so when you are
doing this transformation yes then you
are not transforming the proof at all
yes yes I am okay so before i read the
proof all right i erase this I should
have told me okay so you are just
getting war products like if you have a
true fun and the truth cool then you are
just getting basically the products of
each bits yes also in so in in the old
from system at typically six index pilot
these things right and but now the proof
it will be sort of em index by u 1 u 2 X
1 and X 2 and the owners prober will
write this as f u 1 of x 1 x after you 2
of X 2 alright this is how he's going to
complete this table index by these
things but what they dishonest I mean
the dance you press prove it does we
don't know but it is a new written proof
he has to take all the pairs of
questions in the old one or write down
what the institution dinner that works
multiply to prove systems not only the
labor proper about like any two roses
yeah so the question you have to look at
the acceptance criteria right what you
want from these two bits you're right
you read well if you want them to be in
the particularly the same linear
subspace in both these two proof systems
also this product string will be in the
same I mean the product is just the X
all right i mean system in past nine so
the products they will also be in the
same day in your subspace we get an
interesting proof system but in general
if you start with to proof systems that
are very different acceptance criteria
you know when you look at the
corresponding strings that they won't
have any structure so that's what you
really want that's why he works a nicely
with linear things right we're starting
with with a linear subspace and this
would be very important but yours is not
quite there in our sources it doesn't
leave out the zero now it is a linear
sad face I mean the coal ports is a
linear subspace I leave out the
coordinate that's always 0 right now is
there is this thing I want support a
point over right but it is a linear
subspaces
Oh
Oh
Oh
right some books
absolutely I mean I the best we have a
single proof right and we're asking
queering this proof in cheap places so
this is probably the current
expectations attention attention right
this is what is it how well I mean when
we do this one still lived in your
expansion of the predicate have well
we'll be doing it on a certain term and
nowhere ulema here
so the clear is that if we take the
product of the proof system in fact for
any particular character we take the
minimum we get the minimum distances so
you know I'm not sure quilt design so
right so when we're going to prove
uselessness right we have these T
questions and we're going to want to say
that the distribution of these two bits
is uniform and that's saying that
expectation of any subset of these guys
is unbiased right so we'll take one from
system and look at the bias of one
character on the answers and what I'm
claiming now is that if you take the
product of two systems we get the better
of the two there at the witness didn't
product is I belong to alphabet as I in
section I just needed a dot writes it
exactly right for Happy's where these t
we are asking this two-bit reading these
tidbits from the proof a we're and now
we're looking at the character sorry now
I'm messed up mutation there sorry
so let's let's prove that ml from q1 and
q2 is for them out
and idea of the proof is that if you
just fix any value of Q 2 that gives a
proof system for q1 and then we just
have expectation over q1 and q2 and then
said do this
Oh
and of course once you have this
you can take the product of cake icing
you get the minim I mean the character
is the minimum of the minimum of the
chaos
yeah well k was
so I was saying before you know when I
was wondering about the proof system
with one question on the x one side and
six on the big side side will this term
we can handle this term we have problems
with that term you can hand so now we
just have to define a lot o of proof
system so that each term is handled in
one of the proof system by shuffling
these things around
so what I actually did didn't intend to
do but just want to tell you is that if
you look at the ice proof system what
you'll do is you'll put the one question
on the left side in position I and then
you make all the other guys why and it
turns out that you can bound all
coefficients that contain I and this it
require some work is you can't do by for
your expansion but you have to do these
invariance principle sins and so forth
and all what happens if you just X
always in the same place you put a new
device and know that so did the point is
if you look at something that only
contains why positions okay that
actually piercing the free expansion of
the predicate itself that has to be big
in the owners proof you did when I tell
you to go spine yeah but still look at
the known as proof I look at the
dishonest proof right so look at the
dishonest proof it have inconsistent
long coats everywhere that thing has to
survive I mean if you're looking at all
that doesn't contain anything from the
Exide you know positions that just
contain y variables then we look exactly
the same in the owners proof and and the
and this cheating proof it inconsistent
long talks so that term has to be bad
you know it's we can't fool it somehow
it looks the same with both groups so
that's why you need x and y's in sort of
all positions because you have to make
use of this consistency okay
and I don't know that I can't even do
this proof standing now so there's no
option but you know this is how the
proof films so the great invention is
you know to have this proof you sort of
a new era of proofs that you can the
idea that you can take proof of proof
systems and handle the terms and
different proofs and that sort of was
the great idea that we didn't have any
questions on this
and
so the last thing I want to do is
something a little bit different where
it's a little bit similar hang on review
it and so i'll just change gears a
little bit on a different type of a
bottom ability so we have a case at
formula when this is going to be exactly
k sath so we will have you known nah and
I promise you exist satisfying
assignment
that satisfies Ariel's electors in it's
close
and your test is not enough to find
something that satisfies our little
herbs in each floors but satisficing
than normal cells
so for instance instead of caves where l
is equal to one if you know k is equal
to 3 tempe hard but if l is it would k
is equal to 2 it polynomial time so for
which values of k and l is this np-hard
is not my question so it's an
approximation in a different dimension
what to someone should be K over 2 ok
and want an apple you sure yeah YK with
you because otherwise someone to walk we
should walk up mm-hmm ok so what you're
saying that canary what's the random
thing walk thing that would work out I
mean I don't really see but there should
be a bias if you wish something if you
if you're the best clothes in the sample
you never saw this before but there's an
algorithm up by my crystals right you
don't yet they simply that that's the
case decided until tues that yeah yeah
and the point is that the christus to
shut algorithm works right sorry I
didn't understand this so saleable
what's decreased is to settlement is
that take any take any handset suppose
you have a satisfy a tus at 400 such
Bible and the following algorithm take
an unsatisfied toes and flip one or two
variables so how many people saw this
algorithm before ok so if you didn't
tell
repeated and analyzed it sort of it it's
a very cute double right sammich
earnings arboretum or what this is same
as surely no no no no so this is where
to set start with something arbitrary
take it and not satisfied so son's said
more carefully okay so so as long as
it's not satisfied taking on satisfy
close randomly flip one of its two
variables missile base and it is a
constructive I yourself also know what
smoking yes but this is much simpler
right
so let's
so now have you analyzed with take any
satisfying assignment and look at the
distance from from the thing that will
happen well since this is satisfying it
must be different with one of these two
variables and in the worst case is this
it different impulse and I'm actually
are sure gonna make progress but do I
say we you know it's an unbiased random
walk well normally it's if you look at
the distance to any point is not an
unbiased random walk when we're starting
to get closer we just flip something
randomly like you to move away right so
this is a non biased random walk
and then you sort of think well if you
have lots of satisfying assignment how
can be done by random walk towards all
of them but once you've hit the first
one you sort of get stuck in and don't
move any further sits okay so then when
does this work what we need more general
yeah well as you said right so as long
as the number of satisfying closest is
at least half this would be a numbers
random walk into the work can you make
this deterministic
this is a good homework problem
just do the best this conditional
expectation no I don't know how to make
this rather walk
so if it is strictly greater
from
so if l is actually greater than k
return then you you set up the
corresponding Elfie
so we if we have say three out of five
set I'm rather close the hooks and we
take Adam floor since I will three of
its variable should be satisfied then
and then we this is a solvable LP
because it's all open / 01 and then we
find it and but then in fact anything
that's gated and a half will run to true
and it has to be one variable in each
other things because L is actually
strictly great thinking written on the
other one L is exactly K over to you
want variables equal to one half is a
solution to this LP so this LP is not so
useful and then you have to do something
more but you can make you determine I
don't if like you can think about it
while I'm talking but you know you can
fix also k equal to exactly Alex cyclic
AMP so you think it's hard otherwise and
how do you prove this and means if it is
really high you can just stand on three
sides like if you skated to so in case
if that is great less than K over three
we can in fact just start with a
three-set instance enough k 6 and we
asked to two variables too little to
between each close we start with a
three-set formula Mexico you know the
old periscope is unwritten okay so the
question is the interesting question is
really between the third and a half okay
so the first interesting question is two
out of five shuttle so that you know k
is equal to 58 l is equal to 2 and
that's what this would be great starting
point for reductions to get better
approximately to yourself so this is now
approximation in a different sense is
sort of the worst local situation rather
than sort of the number of constraints
as and the funny thing is the only way
we we could prove this was np-hard was
actually through a label cover scene and
I searched the literature a little bit
but I mean you proved it yourself you
hope that nobody has proved it but and I
had some people did anybody see this so
I want to prove that this is MP hard no
approximation in World whatsoever yeah
that's a good person on Saturday and I
don't get any approximation on this you
know I can't count the number of satisfy
the closest just that there would be
some falsified course i thought that NP
hardness can be always proven
yeah so let's let's prove yeah so that's
a cut knowledge i got introduction would
always give some inapproximability so
i'll let me prove this theorem ok if
this isn't this is ample so this is on
now unpublished it's not clear with spy
because you know we haven't really seen
how far we can push this so this is is
possibly by near Paris train event at
guru Swami but it might do differently
some waters when the smoke clears ok so
for or let's put it like this
there may I think you will get some
inapproximability
what
so now we want to reduction for this
just to make perfectly satisfied to
music please answer yes yeah thank you
you're like ethics right you're like
Apple so how do we prove this so we'll
start with our favorite table cover
so with new all-natural closes okay
Oh
and so will take you know we know me how
we should take these inputs so we'll
take five such inputs and we'll make
sure that two coordinates are truly each
other in each other coordinates at least
20 other five strings is true I'm not
lying below good yeah yeah we have of
course yet for ya has an old country has
belonged all things of course yes sorry
never so we have the reason codes 10
and we we do the same sort of internal
test for 41 44 g set up each DC w what
we take five guys here and finally we'll
take x1 x2 let's go to I 3.45 I start
Expo 15 x 20
right boy
we are still in natural test you know
you test the long courses individually
and you do the natural test across
and I'm sorry and I forget everything of
course is folding and right we really
know we have a five set so we have
negation so we refocus so then I came
that now you want to prove a lemma that
says
if F satisfies all the F closes you know
all the clauses of this type and it
actually depends f is a function right
it depends on the eyes and adjudged
coordinate then in fact it's one
whenever these coordinates are one
that's the only rule what do you mean
depends so it could because it could
depend only on the other ones and we
consider because in whatever X I next
year so I that's not that's not the case
now so what what I mean with the pen the
influence is nonzero yes sir I mean it
exists an X 1 such that f of X 1 is not
equal to f of X 1 this is the pencil
alright so there's some input where we
flip it ok
okay and there is another important such
that f of X 2 so this is let me prove
this is a very simple proof just so we
hire you know two inputs x1 and x2 and
so let's assume yes that is the fact is
minus 1 through okay but is otherwise i
can just reverse the roles of the two Z
so this means that this in fact is equal
to this
I should have done the other way around
these are actually once
and so now you just look at this 5
couple and I think it I came it's a
legitimate fight Apple for a test
so x is any arbitrary input is an
arbitrary input which I'm trying to
prove this I next one the next two other
ones where they put x1 and x2 or the two
things here so if you these two us
drinks are complimentary almost
everywhere right accepted position I and
these are complementary accepted
position J so if you look at the end of
position except I and J these four guys
have to to one's values because their
compliments and if you look at position
I well this is true and one of these
guys is true so two of them it true and
for the same reason two of them of XJ
minus one but now let's apply to these
things if you apply after these things
you have 1111 so for this to survive the
test and actually be satisfied what f of
X has to be true yes so there's no
graduated action just to see sense I
don't know I couldn't find one I work
for two guys I couldn't find one's a lot
of it if you look at sleazo into volume
is y and z and then the next clause is
going to exactly the same place at in
the compliment to find coconut to see
what little bit x 10 it's still just a
guess that's the slingshot close and
then you are two more like when y and z
in one case is going to take white is it
positive and the other case you're going
to take positive negative so doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't quite yet so when you
have x1 x2 x-ray light and you want to
add two new variables y1 in white cash
and in the new classes here in 1k
serving 10 x 10 x two L going sleep your
vector to 25 it's x1 x2 x3 + y1 y2
another one you're doing right are you
verify to fly one white so it's never
wise for you to have the tool a little
better but it's if you know it's you can
add one of the verizon doesn't is too
busy to say sir this was such a nice
proof
just saying so the completeness you're
saying we should add no no no write this
I can always satisfy baidu just
accelerate variables right I mean I
you're asked to feel strong a satisfying
assignment to this new senior be the
same as you said one we said Walter to
trip on through and once Forge and then
you sense like those discourses you said
12 or one what's up to 25 closes so
you're supposed to society's to know me
you're not supposed to satisfy God I
mean you're guaranteed at the two is
satisfiable you just need to search
right one all right that's good for you
must just see doing yeah good who take
yourself enough yeah I didn't eat the
chocolate there and that's what we get
to write the fork to satisfy even one we
have to make sure that because of all
the four guys are are for
so yeah I'm that dilemma fine the
corollary is it so that means that F
actually depends on at most three
variables because if it depended on four
things so if it depend on x1 x2 x3 x4 if
you look at the inputs that has that's
1100 then it should be one did it should
be true by dilemma but sorry no if you
look at 11 minus 11 this should be minus
1 i'm sorry i try to be consistent minus
1 being true is also counterintuitive
but some nights yeah so if you look at
these two it's all dictates this to be
minus 1 but if you negate this thing
these two tix stated to be minus 1 and
in fact yeah so that can't determine
driven and the funny thing is that
that if you take the majority of three
guys it's like it doesn't have to be a
long coat if you take the majority of
three guys it actually contains it
survives this test it satisfied please
this is short but now this is now we're
sort of fine because do you will to
survive the test so G only depends on
three variables and that it's easy to
see if the three variables that Jeep
depends on in the three minor but said
projection if there is no if if they're
not consisted on the projection I mean
if there's none of the elements that G
project on that that F depends on that
in fact it's easy to violate these
closest should i right
but let me write it down
so
Oh
Oh
so I claim the diff killed F and G so
far I've sent me I want to buy one [ __ ]
cross closes the next claim that there
exists a labeling the satisfied at least
nine of all their the labor conditions
and why is this and suppose f you
depends on xi1 xi2 3g depends on
right so I claim that if if there's no
consistency between the projections is
very easy to find the inputs here and
I'm wasn't even going to prove this but
you don't look happy enough
right i just have to find him puts fear
such a tease and then I'm going to ask
right f of X 1 i'll make a close of f of
x1 f of X 2 Geo y 3 to you why for but
these depend on completion time in these
depend on completely different variables
that doesn't project on to what these
depend on so it's very easy to just
construct action wise it's the screws up
and then we done because that will sense
if you just take a random variable on
which it depends will get a distant
lines in number and then in fact you
just need a label covered with one line
soundness which is just some finite
label covers I suppose we get some mean
approximate in them but it's a very
minut it's a relatively small constant
am
so so you are looking at the particular
problem where there is a notion of
strong reset is a closest strongly
satisfied the closest weekly satisfied
okay and then you create a promise
problem out of this yes so so this could
be done like more generally but does is
do these kind of problems I mean are
these kind of problems kind of the same
as CSPs learner instance does dichotomy
over the world so let me tell you my
reason for it so this is now a
completely different problem it's not to
CSP anymore of course now we can start
saying things you know suppose this is
perfectly satisfied but what fraction
can you do blah blah blah but my the
reason I wanted this problem is I wanted
this as a starting point for a job
scheduling a hardness right so what's
your job scheduling right you have lots
of machines and the question is what's
the maximum running time of all the
machines which is a very different
problem from a maxi speed problem
because it sort of you're looking at the
worst local situation now which machine
is the most loaded and then I thought
this would be an excellent starting
point because her here we're sort of
looking at the worst local situation
yeah which clause has the fewest true
literals and so then I wanted this
problem and then we managed to prove
this problem at Emmy couldn't get the
scheduling problems as a reduction from
it so the hope is that I telling you
guys you now get the new fresh tool that
nobody has and you should use this for
reductions yes again I guess
philosophically it's also like related
to the question is where is the hardest
of sad part with it to visit at three
yeah the philosophy is that it should be
a 2 and therefore you know if this
student just should be even for larger
numbers you know whenever you're about
the half that should be it should be
also you know how to prove that or not
yet I mean for other part is not 12 to
five so three out of seven for example
at the same preferred listen yeah yes I
forgot to say this you you you so yes
this proof you if you think about it it
works for any like if I start with three
then in fact F will only if if it
depends on on any particular three
coordinates then you can
do exactly the same trick with the pears
and then it just works sorry yeah so so
this sort complete answers the question
of l / suitcase at you know if l is at
least K over 2 it's easy and if it's
strictly less than carry two it's a
compliment which I felt was you just
find some satisfying because this these
algorithms sort of like Papa Demetrius
if you run it once you've satisfied all
the closest to the can't make progress
and it sort of would be natural because
otherwise you could probably solve this
I mean what sort of remains is a little
bit smaller problem right suppose I
start with a particular problem is as
add you know increased k to k plus 1 and
L 2 n plus 1 by just adding 1 through
and that shouldn't work and yeah so I'm
that was actually the end and what the
things I was planning to say so I think
I'll just give you a longer break